Hallo.
Schau, ist mein Name.
Ich bin einer der zuständige Ärzte in dieser Station
und würde gerne mit Ihnen sprechen.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben, können Sie einfach Bescheid sagen,
dann machen wir ein kurzer Pause.
Alles verständlich?
Ja.
Erst mal, ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihr persönlich stellen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Marianne Schmideskamp.
Marianne, könnten Sie Ihr Nachnamen bestavieren?
Ja, Schmideskamp schreibt sich SCHMIDESKAMP.
Nach dem E, Ida und Emil.
Ida, Emil oder Doppel, Ida?
Nein, Ida, Emil.
Und die letzte, Ida, Ida.
Kampf, Schmideskamp.
Alles klar.
Frau Schmideskamp.
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie denn?
Ich bin 63 Jahre.
62.
Wahnsinn, Sie sind ja noch geboren.
Am 19. Juni 1959.
Wie viel wiegen Sie bitte?
65 Kilo.
65.
Ja.
Und wie groß sind Sie denn?
1,67 m.
Alles klar.
Frau Schmideskamp.
Was fühlt Sie zu uns denn heute?
Ja, ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Seit 3 Tagen ziemlich stark.
Anfang waren die Bauchschmerzen mehr auf der linken Seite im Bauch,
aber sind jetzt seit gestern überall im Bauch.
Seit 2 Tagen haben Sie starke Bauchschmerzen.
Wo genau fühlen Sie die Schmerzen im Oberbauch oder im Unterbauch?
Jetzt überall im Bauch.
Im Anfang war es mehr, in den 1. Stunden war es mehr auf der linken Seite im Bauch,
links im Mittelbauch.
Links im Mittelbauch.
Aber seit wann haben Sie im ganzen Bauch fühlen?
Seit gestern.
Seit 3 Tagen habe ich Schmerzen und seit gestern überall im Bauch.
Sind die Schmerzen gewandert oder ausgestrahlt?
Wie gesagt, im Anfang waren die Schmerzen links.
Dann sind Sie jetzt sozusagen in den ganzen Bauch gezogen.
Ja.
Können Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher brücken, dumpf oder stechen vielleicht?
Ja, Sie sind mehr so dumpf, aber manchmal wären Sie auch stärker, wie eine Welle.
Das dauert dann so 1, 2 Minuten und dann lässt es wieder etwas nach.
Aber die Schmerzen sind immer da.
Aber kommen die Wellen für mich?
Ja.
Alles klar.
Können Sie die Schmerzen bis Ende unseres Gesprächs aushalten oder brauchen Sie ein Schmerzmittel momentan?
Ich kann sie noch aushalten.
Ja, es wäre besser auch für die Diagnose.
Können Sie die Schmerzen einstürfen, zum Beispiel auf eine Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 für einem leichtesten und 10 für unerträglichen Schmerzen entsprechen?
Ja, ich würde sagen 6 bis 7.
6 bis 7.
Haben Sie eine Auslöser bemerkt für die Schmerzen wie Essen, Bewegung?
Nein, habe ich keinen Auslöser bemerkt.
Früher haben Sie solche Beschwerden gehabt oder ist das erst mal aufgeteilt?
Nein, sowas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Haben Sie etwas eingenommen um die Schmerzen zu lindern?
Nein, ich habe mir nur eine Wärmflasche mal auf den Bauch gelegt, aber es hat nichts verändert.
Wärmflasche.
Ihr habt gehört, dass manche Patienten auch Kirschkernkissen benutzen.
Ja, so etwas habe ich aber nicht benutzt.
Ich habe nur eine Wärmflasche benutzt.
Ja, aber keine Linderung.
Aber auch keine Verschlimmerung?
Ja, haben Sie noch, hatten Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Ja, wie ist hier so ein bisschen in den letzten Stunden, ist mir so ein bisschen eher etwas übel, aber ich habe bisher noch nicht erbrochen.
Oder hatten Sie Sortbrennen, Säures auf Stoßen bemerkt?
Nein.
Hatten Sie vielleicht Fieber?
Nein, ich habe in den letzten Wochen kein Fieber gehabt.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Aborder zugenommen?
Ja, ich glaube, ich habe in letzter Zeit etwas abgenommen.
Normalerweise im Winter nehme ich normalerweise immer etwas zu.
Aber jetzt glaube ich, habe ich so in den letzten 5-6 Wochen so 2-3 kg abgenommen.
Und wie ist jetzt Ihr Appetit?
Ja, sei es gut.
Seit 3 Tagen nicht gut.
Seitdem ich die Bauchschmerzen habe, habe ich kaum etwas gegessen.
Nur immer etwas getrunken.
Es muss schwer sein für Sie.
Ist Ihnen Herzrasen oder Herzklopfen aufgefallen oder vielleicht Husten Sie?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Ich habe zwar vom Husten, ich habe ein Asthma, allergisches Asthma, behandle ich mit Sprace, aber das hat sich nicht verschlechtert jetzt.
Seit wann leiden Sie Asthma?
Seit 25 Jahren.
Und der Name wissen Sie?
Das eine ist Saugutamol.
Ja.
Und das eine heißt, das ist ein schwieriger Name, Buddisunit.
Buddisunit, ja.
Auch die Dosis wissen Sie?
Von Buddisunit nehme ich zweimal, einmal morgens, einmal abends.
Und von Saugutamol mehr bei Bedarf.
Hatten Sie auch Luftnot?
In letzter Zeit nicht.
In letzter Zeit war das mit dem Asthma ganz gut.
Dann nehmen Sie Ihre Medikamente regelmäßig ein, ne?
Ja.
Und ich möchte noch ein paar Fragen über Ihre Krankengeschichte stellen.
Sie haben Asthma genannt, ansonsten haben Sie noch weitere Krankheiten?
Ja, ich habe eine so eine chronische Schildrösenentzündung mit einer, oder Arzt sagt, eine mit einer leichten Unterfunktion.
Und da muss ich auch ein Medikament nehmen.
Welche denn?
Das Medikament heißt Ältiroxin 75, nehme ich morgens eine Tablette.
Morgens eine.
Und was noch?
Sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente.
Hatten Sie Schweißausbrüchen oder Schüttelfrost?
Nein, habe ich in letzter Zeit nicht gehabt.
Auch gut.
Wurde Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, vor fünf Jahren wurde die Gallenblase entfernt, weil ich hatte Gallensteine und da hatte ich dann auch einmal eine Bauchspeichel-Entzündung durch einen Gallenstein.
Und dann wurde operiert.
Sonst habe ich keine Operationen.
Hatten Sie Komplikationen dabei?
Nein.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder U-Verträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ja, Allergien, deswegen habe ich auch dieses Asthma.
Wurde gesagt, das ist ein allergisches Asthma.
Man vermutet einmal Hausstaub.
Auch im Frühjahr bei Polen, Polenflug.
Besonders Birkenpolen und Haselnuss.
So jetzt fängt das jetzt so an, wenn es warm wird, dann geht das wieder los mit dem Asthma verstärkt.
Aber zurzeit geht es noch.
Wie äußert sich der Allergien?
Ja, dass ich mitunter schlechter Luft bekomme oder meine Augen pränen und meine Nase läuft.
Und laufende Nase.
Alles klar.
Rauchen Sie Frau Schmidiskamp?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Sehr gut.
Wie sieht es mit Ihrem Perioden aus?
Wer kommen Sie noch?
Nein, schon seit 10 Jahren nicht mehr.
Seit 10 Jahren.
Wir trinken Sie Alkohol ab und zu oder allgemein?
Vielleicht einmal pro Woche trinke ich ein Glas Wein.
Also einmal in der Woche, aber nicht mehr.
Ein Glas Wein.
Bitte fühlen Sie sich nicht angegriffen, dass das eine Routine Frage ist.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Wir sind fast fertig Frau Schmidiskamp.
Aber ich möchte auch einige Informationen sammeln über Ihre Familie und Sozialleben.
Alles in Ordnung?
Ja.
Also leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Der Vater ist gestorben.
Da war er 75 Jahre alt an Darmkrebs.
Tut mir leid.
Und die Mutter, die ist 83 Jahre alt.
Die hatte einen leichten Schlaganfall vor 3 Jahren.
Aber so weit geht es ihr ganz gut und hat einen etwas erhöhten Blutdruck.
Aber sonst geht es sehr gut.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, eine Schwester.
Die ist 66 Jahre alt.
Da wurde vor einem Jahr im Darm ein bösartiger Polyp operiert.
Das wird jetzt kontrolliert und das ist wohl im Augenblick in Ordnung.
Momentan ist sie ausgeheizt, ne?
Ja.
Was machen Sie dann beruflich?
Ich bin Verkäuferin in einem Schuhgeschäft.
In einem?
Schuhgeschäft für Stur.
Verkauf ist Stur.
Sehr gut.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder im Privatleben?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sind Sie frei?
Ja, ich lebe mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Haben Sie auch Kinder?
Ja, 2 Kinder.
Die sind 32 Jahre alt und 34 Jahre alt.
Die haben beide auch dieses allergische Asthma.
Zwei und?
Können Sie die Jahre wiederholen?
32 und 34.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine lange Reise gehabt?
Nein.
Haben Sie vielleicht etwas Ungewöhnliches gegessen?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Nein.
Jetzt haben wir unsere Gespräche beendet.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es ein sehr ungewöhnliches ist.
Ich bin ein sehr ungewöhnliches.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es ein Problem mit Ihren
Magen sein.
Also, dann würde ich auch gerne wissen, ob Sie Probleme
beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang haben.
Wasserlassen ist in Ordnung.
Stuhlgang habe ich jetzt seit 3 Tagen nicht mehr gehabt.
Normalerweise habe ich jeden Tag Stuhlgang.
Ich habe mich nicht mehr in Ordnung.
Aber seit 3 Tagen, seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, habe ich keinen Stuhlgang mehr.
Ja.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie die Farbe oder
Konsistusveränderung bemerkt?
Beim Stuhl?
Ich habe den Eindruck,
dass es in den letzten Wochen immer ein bisschen schwieriger war.
Manchmal war es auch viel schleimbar.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen
und einmal Blut abnehmen.
Ich würde noch ein Bild erst
dames machen.
Und gegebenenfalls eine Zitieuntersuchung.
Dann können wir weiter sehen.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Nein, im Augenblick nicht.
Alles klar.
Dann sehen wir uns per Körperlich untersuchen.
Okay, gut.
Können andere Kolleginnen und Kollegen fragen?
Gerne.
Können Sie Wind abgeben?
Nicht so gut.
Seit wann haben Sie das nicht?
Auch so seit 2-3 Tagen nicht.
Okay, danke.
Ich würde gerne wissen,
werde einem Netzgeschick?
Wir sehen.
Wir haben sehen.
Der Patient hat große Probleme.
6-7 Abdomen schmerzen.
Deswegen, was machen wir?
Zum Beispiel unterirdischen und Vitalparameter
so schnell wie möglich messen.
Was sehen Sie?
Es wurde einmal gefragt vom Kollegen,
wie das mit den Schmerzen ist.
Ob ich etwas gegen Schmerzen brauche.
Ich habe es Nein gesagt.
Man kann natürlich
während der Anamnese
auch vielleicht schon mal den Blutdruck messen
oder vorsichtig den Bauch abfühlen.
Das kann man machen.
Aber in diesem Fall,
der Patient oder ich habe es nicht.
Das ist ein unklares Abdomen.
Ich würde es nicht ganz so dringlich sehen,
Vitalparameter zu überprüfen,
wie bei einem Verdacht auf Herzinfarkt.
Oder so etwas.
Oder auf ein Gefäßennotfall.
Allerdings sollte man zeitnah
schon versuchen, sie zu überprüfen.
Das ist ein unklares Abdomen.
Ich möchte wissen.
www.athleteclone.de
Es ist immer immer ein livre Begriff.
Man sollte zeitnah versuchen,
sich ein Bild zu machen.
Die Anamnese ist nicht zu lang auszudehnen.
Die ganz gründliche Anamnese.
Ich verlerre erstmal die Kernfragen zu stellen.
Und vielleicht einen Bauchpapieren.
Den Blutdruck zu messen,
als Geschippel.
Von mir aus, Jan.
Ja, auch.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Würde ich gerne vorstellen, hatten Sie Zeit?
Ja, habe ich.
Frau Schmidis Kampf Mariana.
Sie ist eine 63-jährige Patientin.
Unser Patient ist 1 Meter 67, groß und 65 Kilogramm schwer.
Heute kam zu uns mit seit circa drei Tagen bestehenden,
starker, dumpfer und kampfartige linkseitige Bauchschmerzen
mit Wanderung im ganzen Bauch seit gestern.
Ja, also mit abdominellen Schmerzen.
Ja.
Abdominellen Schmerzen, ja.
Also die Schmerze wurde sie bei 6 bis 7 von 10 auf eine Schmerzkala angegeben.
Ja.
Und daneben beklagte sie auch noch sehr ohne Emesis und Inoperanz.
Seit drei Tagen können sie nicht Stuhlgang entleeren.
Ja.
Letzter Stuhlgang vor drei Tagen.
Bei sonst anemnestisch regelmäßigen Stuhlgang.
Ja.
Und daneben erwähnte sie über Stuhlverhalt und Schwierigkeiten beim Windeabgabe.
Die Anwendung von Warmfläche habe ihr keine Linderung herbeigeführt.
Und in der Vegetation am Nese zeigt sich eine Gewichtsabnahme von bis 3 kg innerhalb von 6 Wochen.
Und die Fragen nach Fieber, Sortbrennen, Husten, Düstbne oder Wasserlassenproblemen wurden vereint.
In der Vorgeschichte zeigt sich eine allergische Asthma seit 25 Jahren.
Und Hypotheorien.
Also.
Hypotheorien gibt es eine Ursache der Hypotheorien?
Ja.
Als Ursache postwahrscheinlich Aschimoto Thiroiditis.
Okay.
Und er folgte eine Koalizistikdomi wegen Koalizistitis und Koalitiasis vor fünf Jahren.
Mit Begleitpankreatitis?
Ja.
Patientin hat eine Pankreatitis vor fünf Jahren.
Die OP war komplikationslos.
Also als Medikation nehme Sie Salbutamol, Spray bei Bedarf.
Und es so nicht, Spray zweimal.
Und Alturoxin 75 Mikrogramm einmal.
Okay.
Gibt es eine auffällige Familie, Familie in einem Nese?
Sein Vater.
Ihr Vater?
Ja, ihr Vater ist an Darmkrebs verstorben mit 75.
Der Vater verstarb mit 75 an einem Kolon Neoplasma oder Kolon-CA.
Ja.
Und bei der Mutter besteht eine stark gehafte Apoplex vor drei Jahren
und Arteerlipertonie.
Und bei der Schwester besteht eine operierte Polypectomy bei ihr verfolgt.
Ja.
Sie sei Verkäuferin vom Beruf, nicht stressig bei der Arbeit,
verheiratet mit, lebe mit ihrer Mann zusammen
und habe zwei Kinder, welche auch an Asthma leiden.
Okay.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es ein Illus sein kann.
Aber als Alternative kommt eine Infektioskolitis
oder eine Reisdarm-Syndrom im Betracht.
Um mein Verdacht zu bestätigen,
wieder ich zuerst die Patientköpferlich untersuchen.
Besonders achte ich auf die Darmgeräusche.
Okay.
Wie werden Sie die Gewichtsabnahme in den letzten sechs Wochen?
Ja, eine Malinität sollen wir auch in Erwägung ziehen.
Okay.
Aber andere Be-Symphtomatik wurde verneint.
Ja.
Und einmal würde ich auch die digitale Untersuchung machen
und einmal Blut abnehmen mit Entzündungsparameter.
Ja.
Daneben würde ich einmal eine Abdomensonographie bei ihr durchführen.
Und eine Abdomenübersichtsaufnahme.
Gut, gegebenenfalls eine CT-Aufnahme.
Okay.
Also ich denke auch, es besteht sicherlich eine Sub-Ilius-
oder Ilius-Symphtomatik bei der Gewichtsabnahme.
Also muss man, und bei dem Alter der Patientin,
auch bei der familiären Grundbelastung,
doch auch an einen Malignen-Prozess denken.
Und differenzial diagnostisch könnte man eventuell
eine Sigma-Divertikolithis in Erwägung ziehen.
Der Schmerz begann, glaube ich, im linken Bauchbereich.
Und Fieber hat die Patientin jetzt zwar nicht berichtet,
aber das müssen wir hier nochmal genau überprüfen.
Manchmal denken die Patienten ja auch nicht dran und messen.
Ja, kommen partipisch manchmal.
Und sie hat zwar auch einen voroperierten Bauch
nach der Echiolizistektomie,
aber da glaube ich jetzt nicht,
dass diese Voroperation jetzt ursächlich
für diese Beschwerden sein kann.
Ja, ich glaube auch so.
Wenn die Ilius sich erhärtet,
würde ich der Patient stationa aufnehmen
und Nahrungskarenz anfangen.
Und auch nachdem ich den Zugang angelegt habe,
auch Infusion, Therapie anordnen.
Also ich denke, Sie haben das gut gemacht,
systematisch gemacht, allerdings haben Sie einmal
sich etwas von mir verwirren lassen,
weil ich dann sehr schnell gesagt habe,
ich habe auch ein allergisches Asthma
und da haben Sie Ihre Fragestellungen etwas verlassen.
Da haben Sie vorher nicht gefragt,
der Patient sagt, ich habe seit drei Tagen Bauchschmerzen
und ich habe seit drei Tagen,
tut es mir weh,
und da haben Sie nicht sofort gefragt,
wann war der letzte Stuhlgang?
Ja, das ist mir ein Erkrankte.
Schon eine wichtige Frage im Anfang gewesen.
Das haben Sie später dann gefragt.
Ich habe das ganz bewusst gemacht,
da war ich etwas...
Ich habe meine Kolleginnen danach gefragt.
Also wichtig ist, dass Sie versuchen,
ruhig bei Ihrem Schema zu bleiben.
Bauchschmerzen seit drei Tagen,
wann war der letzte Stuhlgang?
Und man sagt, der Patientin vor drei Tagen
und sonst habe ich aber jeden Tag Stuhlgang.
Das ist schon mal, wir nennen das ja,
Red Flag.
Aber man muss sich dann schon aufpassen,
dass man da auch versucht,
durch die gezielte Anamnese da auch dann beizubeiben.
Und wenn ich jetzt gemein bin und das Asthma erwähne,
dann haben Sie bei dem Asthma nachgefragt,
aber das mit dem Stuhlgang dann leider etwas vernachlässigt,
da passen Sie drauf auf.
Das kann in der Prüfung auch passieren,
dass jemand so etwas Gemeines macht.
Genau, aber ansonsten haben Sie die Medizin,
die Krüfte denke ich, sehr gut gebracht.
Denken Sie dran, gegenüber dem Oberarzt
nicht von Bauchschmerzen zu sprechen,
sondern abdomineller Schmerz.
Das wäre noch mal ganz wichtig.
Mir ist ein bisschen aufgefallen,
im Anfang, wenn Sie gefragt haben,
waren Sie etwas ungeduldig,
dann lassen Sie den Kuli dann ruhig weg.
Oder das möglichst nicht machen.
Das fiel mir nur auf.
Aber ansonsten fand ich das sehr gut.
Sie haben das durchaus auch sehr systematisch gemacht.
Wann haben Sie Prüfung?
Dienstag.
Ich bin da ganz zuversichtlich,
dass Sie das gut machen.
Da wünsche ich Ihnen dafür viel Erfolg
und ein gutes Ergebnis.